we all know which group is suffering
most in Trump's America
that's right men did you know an
overpowering 34% of district court
judges are women ladies how much more
the courts do you need to control home
you're already unlucky enough to hold
the scales
libellus it's time to stand at attention
because shoulder curtains please there's
a war on men something ominous is
happening to men in America a war on men
the Liberals war on men is working
men have been marginalized since the
days of the Mayflower would women
tricked us into wearing those stupid
buckles on our ass women had all the fun
back then
battleground won Miss America it's an
institution so American the winner has
to marry the country for a year before
getting traded in for a younger fresher
model but this beauty parade is in the
midst of some terrifying changes and you
know what it's making me Miss America
for the first time in the organization's
history Miss America will be led by
women we are no longer a pageant we are
a competition we will no longer have a
swimsuit competition we will no longer
judge our candidates on their outward
physical appearance that's huge yeah
rusev sadness I get it stop
appropriating male culture huge is our
word for describing bowel movements to
friends and strangers you see we're
losing more than just a swimsuit
competition here we're losing a
formative experience I'm worried about
that young boy out there watching Miss
America today if he's never taught to
rank women based on their looks he might
grow up ugly in the content of women's
characters wounds have sadness yes
we men are being persecuted aside from a
total monopoly on power judging women
based on their looks was always and the
assault continues battleground to
exercise women are constantly shaming us
men to hit the gym more mocking us just
because one time we got winded ordering
GrubHub and now they're ganging up on us
with help from my number one enemy
science dads who exercise might have
smarter babies researchers arrived at
the conclusion after studying mice what
they found was that exercise changes the
brains of male animals that could later
affect the brains of their potential
offspring badass that guy can squat one
whole toddler this study is total BS
scientists want us to think we're
responsible for the health of the fetus
but that's just another way for the
matriarchy to regulate men's bodies my
body my choice I'll trademark that later
we men don't need to work out more
women's bodies are temples but men's
bodies are sheds squats sturdy and once
I found a spider in there
women put yourselves in our shoes comfy
I know can you imagine if you had to
stay healthy for a prolonged period of
time strictly for the health of your
unborn child
I'm talking like days but the male
persecution isn't over our final
battleground networking women have
always dominated professional networking
that's why men are forced to seek refuge
in clubs boardrooms and the corridors of
power but there's good news one brave
man in California is fighting back
against women only events DJ Mandy mixes
organized a girls night out dance party
at the Spring Hill Suites in Oceanside
open to ladies 21 and over
DJ Mandy was shocked when she and the
hotel were sued accused of sexism
against men the man filing the lawsuit
steve fries fry tried to enter DJ
Mandy's girls night out dance party but
was told he quote could not attend yes
nothing says masculinity like tattling
on girls who were mean to you
yes man's van man's man this guy Steve
Frey is a hero a freedom fighter for a
group called the National Coalition for
men whose logo is a male symbol with
three additional dicks these guys know
that progress anywhere is a threat to me
everywhere that's why they developed a
noble habit of suing women's only events
like when they went after a cycling
festival for including a ladies
activities day because women would have
been admitted for free Oh Bravo
women shouldn't be able to cycle without
paying their fair share I assume that's
why we taxed tampons so thanks for
standing up for men Steve you're a
strong soldier in this war which we are
on the cusp of winning women I'll be
honest we're about to lose this thing
you're sustained attacks on men have
gone on too long we are powerful alphas
and also constantly victimized so I want
to offer you a truce here is the
historic men and women peace accords
women if you'll stop this oppressive
crusade towards equality we men are
prepared to offer the following we
promise to read the first three
sentences of susan b anthony Zwick a PDA
page and we'll reopen negotiations on
the existence of this so-called female
orgasm
although I'll believe it when I see it
let's end this senseless war on men once
and for all women our balls are in your
court opposers are there any three words
more exciting than click and subscribe
yes Hillary shot Lincoln subscribe now
and find out the truth they don't want
you to know and by day I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts without
clicking subscribe do it